[Musique]
merci
vous savez tous que le Sri Lanka est l'un des
pays les plus pollués du monde,
donc nous, les Sri Lankais, utilisons beaucoup d'
articles en plastique si vous regardez les chiffres
euh 10 20 millions de sacs à provisions sont
utilisé par jour et 10 millions de grosses bouteilles
sont utilisées par jour presque tous les objets
partent en décharge
[Musique] les
jauges étrangères [Musique] [Musique] sont déjà interdites mais on
sait que la encore certains
producteurs continuent à produire et par
exemple le midi c'est  ah interdit de euh
produire en plastique déjà mais je
vois qu'à part dans les chaînes de supermarchés
dans d'autres points de vente encore on pourrait
voir vous savez ils aiment une
industrie artisanale ils continuent de faire ça
[Musique]
étranger
pour recycler 400 tonnes métriques  par mois
actuellement, nous produisons environ 250 tonnes métriques
par mois, donc en fait 10 bouteilles
sont utilisées pour fabriquer un t-shirt
et 27 bouteilles sont utilisées pour fabriquer une
robe de graduation
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]